you worked with Daniel day-lewis right
yeah okay now that guys like considered
one of the great I thought it was really
authorized you didn't fall in love with
him but okay well the best part was is
that I was supposed to be falling in
love with him in it you know right so I
was great so fine in other words you're
there with Daniel day-lewis supposed to
be falling in love with him do you
literally need to fall in love with him
well he's not difficult to fall in love
well yeah I mean he's you know he's
especially now I don't know what he
would be like on like Gangs of New York
because method so you know it might be a
completed was he with you was he like
it's very he's very message did you have
to like call him his character name when
you were all did he call you you or your
character an Aikido Guido I was
Stephanie yeah it was really he sees you
by the Trapster is horrible and he goes
Stephanie hi Stephanie oh wait a second
uh Daniel day-lewis is on the phone yes
Daniel you who you right now oh hey okay
I'm gonna call the link some shoes down
in Manchester I just wanted to give you
a ring how are you wait who is that you
know over how's Winnipeg it's very good
Daniel are you Guido or Daniel day-lewis
how is your brother Oliver I love it
yeah like I'm a nobody
what are you doing he's so happy right
now he's a warning me to do this show
for so long and now he's here there he
is okay nice Olly I'm not being bad no
no I love it
thank you for calling it
you